you already know what it is man cool a
Capcom sitting here with my friend Bob
aka logic yes listen man distortion
that's personal Oh congratulations
I was talking to G earlier I'm like yoga
I just think I've seen you guys it's
[__] come up with my own eyes I know
that's real and I'm like a real thing
that's like watching my kids grow up
like in that scene that you guys are way
but you know it's like it's like wow my
friends are really [__] out here you
know you twenty thousand [__] people
you were one of the very first like
radio station interviews I had ever done
so that's like really cool that you've
like been able to be here and like every
every every tour I've seen you I've been
to every tour yes while so it's really
fun this one's crazy yeah like
especially yeah it's it's definitely
like um it's a dope eclectic like it's
there's yg and yoga you know there's
logic and gez yeah your stuff in G easy
to go headline in the tour together yes
you guys share a lot of fans but you
also have your own fans that's why it's
wild man it's like so tonight like and I
love it man it's just I don't know it's
so weird and we're so like opposite but
not it's weird but especially as people
were like very similar cuz he's a good
person
you guys are both the greatest guys I
was just talking to him I was like hey
man
so you party and you like go out [__]
logics well the buzz play [__] halo
[__] what do you guys hang out like I've
never seen you I've had your crew come
out and party with me at the club yeah I
remember six his birthday one year he
was out of here oh man him and render
came to my club I got a [__] blast
for his birthday oh my go
where's my dick bro why'd you come help
I don't but it's but like you said you
got the other day you guys are both good
people you guys are both [__] hip hop
in yeah and you guys both are
appreciative of this culture and I think
it's it's it's really dope do you feel
the difference now that if I feel like
since the album came out there your
profiles recent so much do you feel the
difference like when you go out oh I
feel like I can't go anywhere without
being recognized like anywhere so that's
pretty wild
and I'm very low-key longer super
low-key do whatever so even still and
then it's like one person will be like
oh la dude
and there was that and then it's this
and I'm like oh [__] okay and then I
bounced and it's not like I I mean I'd
love to do it but ditches the influx of
people and all outside like housing
[__] middle of nowhere Texas or
Manila telling me this but yeah it was
ants I've got got your road manager's
name yeah it was wild like you showed up
your homes oh yeah and I got ya showed
up to the hotel I'm like how'd you guys
even find us it was so awesome but I
mean it's crazy but it's like it's also
lets me know like where I'm at like I
went to the mall and my god before I
even walk in the mall there's like five
kids outside oh my god yeah then I walk
in the wall you go to X of zoomies and
there's the dudes working there and then
the kids and then the other you're not
like oh [__] like this is weird
are they so when you're sure like Hot
Topic yeah yeah it's not my shirt how
crazy is that yeah it was great kids
going to you I need to go to Hot Topic
yeah Urban Outfitters that's great Urban
Outfitters like really doesn't name they
hold up albums like the vinyls but it's
great she is different but it's like um
I still feel very like I've changed
so much as a man for the better yeah but
like who I am and what I stand for it
all of that is still the same let's do
what it's always been and I think that's
another reason why not out and I don't
run around I don't do this because I
just don't I don't want to I don't want
anything to try to incept my mind or my
way of thinking or Who I am as a man
so I'd rather just kind of keep to my
circle and just stay positive you have
one of the most famous interview clips
now and I'm like I don't [__] with
nobody
yeah literally hit nobody that's real I
don't [__] me that way you can ask any
of my homie yo Mike so rude as hell that
was not family anyway no but I was
saying like it's all about keeping
people around me for 15 years like
that's real never changes it is what it
don't get me wrong like you know some
homies go so Clark or so this that it's
just always is the evolution of like you
know people didn't go off to do their
own thing it's tough I definitely for me
like you know there's on this tour like
you know some of the other other other
cats go on this tour like yeah really
dope okay nobody could I can't even
catch them through that but when I seen
him it's all of you know what I see
something is nothing but love like it's
all good all of you sometimes are just
so cool
but I guess that stood that stick that
thing about me really like
and they know that because I'm being the
cut yeah I don't want to get in nobody's
business I'm gonna get in nobody's way
[__] with nobody on this day I just
never I just keep to me because if I
keep to me
you can't nobody say nothing can't
nobody try to it's just like you're
gonna get caught up on the bullsh
my favorite album of yours obviously
only have two I mean if you've got any
one that's very good
well that's like a base I always have
arguments with my friends that are big
fans I mean cool all big fans of you I'm
a huge under under pressure as well I
figured out smart yeah but what I really
appreciated about the album is just our
honesty with your father
how's your dad doing man how how how you
pops do in the relationship you guys
well I'd say you man me I haven't man
it's like there's ups and downs and
that's probably all say on camera but
there's always ups and downs with family
in this event but I'm focused on my wife
focused on the fam
I'm focused on the people that are here
now that I'm focused on building my own
family and learning from the best
I mean I'm sure you have kids okay
Congress a didn't happen I mean a week
no not yet I mean you guys yeah we're
young man my wife's 24 so like she has
her incredible just everything she does
her vlogs to her like she wants to get
into fashion there's all these great
things and I want her to enjoy her youth
I think we should enjoy our youth is
that question but I definitely want to
lose to have children we already know
like what our kids names are we gonna
talk about I've never seen this tattoo
on your hand here oh yeah this is sure
the camera happy way it's a happy wife
happy life
I was just go right now did you did she
then you know some people will see that
be like did your wife make you get that
or is that kind of like a reminder my
dummy is that well you know for years
somehow one of those dudes who's like
whipped like [__] that I me and my wife
we have a communication I respect her as
a woman she respects me as a man I don't
tell her what the [__] to do
she doesn't tell me he's so the tattoo
when you get a tattoo like that it isn't
almost like a reminder which you know
like you know look at the end of the
year logic your famous [__] rapper
sometimes show it like some [__]
thought comes up John yeah and you're
like volapük
okay I got it originally I wanted to you
know my ring finger because my tour
manager
Robert has his wife's initials on the
other on a real finger but the guy told
me he was like it's not good that's not
a safe place to get it level blah
whatever so I had to go anyway but I
like this yeah I'm glad I got it and I
just I hurt I had never heard the same
and I never thought I was gonna ever
have tattoo but it's true I randomly
heard it and it's the true she and his
in
next day I got I got it so true me let's
talk about Bobby Tarantino I'm Tarantino
late this is so five legs I'm so excited
now technically it's eight records or
suddenly it's a track race right these
records two skids one intro okay yes I
listened to it front to back a few times
um slave to is before slave would yes I
don't explain that to me I just wanted
you said you had a story about I
actually do have those are my favorite
records on the props lay man sleep to
sleep to is my favorite but I love both
of them no I love that everybody can
always have a favorite or this event and
not I really love more than anything is
that I put this up for a fun and that's
how it's being received something for
fun something for summer which is super
dope so check this [__] out so I I saw
like there was a couple people on
Twitter and they were like oh you know
this kind of sounds like Rambo from you
know from Bryson tiller didn't do it up
and I was like oh okay I see a couple of
people saying this and it was around the
time that I was annotating on genius cuz
I'd love to go in and like do all that
there's no don't
yes so basically I was like oh well let
me clear this up now originally the
entire mixtape for the most part was
going to be classic mix what a mixtape
really is course which is rapping over
other people's beats and what's up
you've got classics over the poly means
that I still perform through this death
yeah that's true yeah I mean you can
call class exactly did they do it so I
knew that that's originally what it was
gonna be it was gonna be like 80% you
know other known beans and then like 20%
of mine and then not even halfway
through the mixtapes creation I had a
phone call with my manager and he put it
this way he was like he was like you
need to look at where you are and where
music is right now and he was like you
want to reach as many people as you can
with his mixtape all right and I was
like yes it he was like then you have to
make it all original because you don't
you can't put it on Spotify you can't
put on spot if I can't have exactly and
I tell right that's how everyone would
sue that's what I'm saying cuz now
it's like you're asking kids to go to
dad pit fit down with God bless ya if ya
say do it you got it down like even as
if you gonna [__] you're gonna dip in
it's an extra step
yeah rather than like if somebody's like
yo you do that new magic mixtape it's
like nah fam where is it
Oh on your phone it's everywhere it's on
Soundcloud that's part Apple music it's
on it and it's so much easier and it's
funny now because everything is
instantaneous all media is actually
through your phone now for the most part
so that's why being able to bypass going
to a website to download it on your
laptop to then sync it to your phone in
this and all that so originally that
song was gonna be over Rambo oh okay and
now here's what's really cool about this
and I and this is what I love about
artists when they like especially
because it true all two are is like love
inspiration they does so what we did was
is obviously didn't do it over the beat
that is similar to be similar vibe and
it's the same key because what I rigidly
was going to do it was to rainbow and
rap genius saw my annotation and they
tweeted it was like oh we thought this
sounded like pen griffey you know I mean
I just like her stuff thought it was
write familiar because the lyrics and
the melody and all that's completely
different and I was like oh yeah because
and I never said that this is nothing
I'm very weird about reaching out to
people because I never went I never want
to just like work with somebody you'll
be like yo what's up fam like I'm just I
noticed it like you you've napped that
that's not been your you oh yeah pass
I'm just but I'm very like respectful of
others I don't want to I don't want to
like I don't want to reach out to Bryson
tiller and go y'all what's up fam let me
get a verse like he plays video games
like I'm like what's up fam let's play
some halo like let's play Call of Duty
like that's how I am so but I even said
it so when they said oh he doesn't did
it up and I responded I was like yeah
like brycie tiller is special and he's a
gamer and then he responded to me and
was like oh again he must have read my
annotation what I said about how it
originally was gonna be on his beat and
you know and I was like much love to him
but I couldn't do if I wanted it to be
streamed I couldn't just do that so you
know he switched it up about he goes I
got the beat if you
fam so I've been talking to him about
doing like my own a little remix how do
you weigh maybe which is really just for
the face yeah that's what I'm saying but
that's what I love man especially about
artists like that who are just so open
and just you know and just just so cool
about now why why the two before the one
cuz I want to betray Oh cuz you know
everybody's asking me like wow whoa
sleeve - before One Lives idea what
about Star Wars because a Star Wars is
backwards - oh damn I didn't think about
that
no [__] I'm just gonna say that I'm
like stuff there you go yeah yeah you
suck my dick
san Bao would hey so what are you
playing right now well first of all I
remember we talked right would like ps4
and Xbox one it dropped yes and you had
super beef with Xbox one yeah
in our interview literally be like you
for Xbox one all right I know that your
later ups I saw you posted the big halo
toy you got oh it's the [__] top yeah
three four game ever it's so dope I
don't actually hate Xbox like it's just
it's all about fresh are you still what
run home computer school I love
PlayStation that's my [__] like I'm
waving the PlayStation plan forever and
I actually use a xbox controller for my
pc is when I'm on the road I have my PC
it's a 14 inch razor and it is not
serious it is incredible we're playing
right now I'm playing mega size 5 and
I'm playing The Witcher 3 those are my
main ones I also have doom and iOS Super
Meat Boy
well I played it and I've gotten about
half of it
you know and then I just like I think I
got I just about playing it and I'm like
me I got it I got it yeah yeah so I know
I'm on that [__] I think it's my third
playthrough so I'll discuss like I just
[__] will play so many games like
tell me what is what are some television
shows you're watching right everyone you
know binge watching
oh no no Road Rick and Morty I love Rick
and Morty okay but I haven't believed oh
[__] you know watching right now
[__] this is some like it's like the
most anti hip-hop [__] a lot of waste
coming yo fam I've been on The Bachelor
red my wife yo it's kinda tight like
what do you think about are you thinking
about like these [__] who are
like like yo like some of this Mike you
know watches often that Housewives
[__] I can't say it's so like it
will be on while I'm in bed and I was
like yo you really are watching these
old rich white ladies [__] cry like
what the [__] is over this reality TV is
because like these people live
vicariously do is it's the ultimate
source of entertainment because that's
what we do let me think about baseball
basketball football in this one air I
can't believe in that play I can't
believe you took that shot like mama
like shut the [__] up like you're not
taking the shot you're they're telling
him what he would do if you were in but
you're not so shut the [__] up but
that's why it's so great because it's
like I can't believe she's with Chad
Chad such an [__] like I don't know
but I love it I'm gonna tell you it was
something like it's a fun thing to do
with my wife like it's really cool we
even have like a sheet that we filled
out before to the first episode and we
like read all their BIOS on like who we
thought would be like don't you play
fantasy Bachelorette like did you get I
don't do a trap [__] right I got [__]
with my life and it's so much fun type
oh yeah on the album do you have a wife
where you think Def Jam you sold more
than that pop [__] cuz everyone I got a
TV no no no she didn't even drop
anywhere near me what I'm talking about
in there is just in [__] general and
I'm not even talking about rap I'm
talking about punk gems ik but it's just
like in general you'll never hear me
shots at nobody because I have no
[__] problems of anybody above a lot
just like Bobby Tarantino always turn up
logic try to rap on some traffic just
meat being fun having fun so I'm like
cuz I'm sold
I've sold a lot more records than a lot
of pop artists but I'm not gonna take a
shot and I'm pop and for everybody out
there that doesn't know the intro and
you just play it backwards you're
essentially saying I put out two albums
yeah yeah I'm trying to have fun
and there's another album that is going
to be worked on that will come out next
year I mean you know me every year like
to do something god what song this is
good and there's you know songs I feel
good about and that's what it is but
yeah little stuff like that or like some
people were trying to say like is he
taking jabs to Kanye when I talk about
you know what it's like yeah cuz I have
a line around like I'm angrier than
Kanye when he's talking about clothes
there's a fashion line so basically it's
a rap line about fashion fashion line
it's a play on words but it's like no
here's my idol who is like it is so
passionate so passionate so in fact that
he can be a god of Wrath and then step
over here and try to do something else
which is doing very well but not be
respected or looked down upon in this
lane it's frustration that's how I felt
before about hip hop as well so it's
really incredible to like relate to that
but yeah with me like if I ever had an
issue with anybody I will say your name
like I will say your name but I wouldn't
like I don't [__] around like would be
like some people just think like it's
okay I've never had a rap beef I've
never had and I never will see look beef
is when two people willingly participate
in conflict period so if anybody has a
problem with me they have a problem
there is no beef because I would never
indulge in sub-state you know to me like
I'm just a positive dude and anybody who
would hate on me is just like and like
him and like you said you don't put
yourself in in the situation's or the
environments for like weird rap [__] to
spark up like a lot of that [__] comes
from like going to the [__] nightclub
yeah and I think it's also like glue
yeah like bro I rap about sauna rooms
too
reading books being married my dear well
I was so excited when I saw you I put
the artwork up for wrist oh [__] yeah
listen man listen clips for me come on
it's outcasted then clips personal yeah
but that's huge
yo I just to me there's like I mean push
the T is I'm a seasoned grabbed me he
might be talked in a long time he's
amazing
I mean he's incredible but to see to rep
guys get on a record like that man how
did I mean obviously I know that you
live in LA close with no ID yeah but how
did the push it to you bro conversation
happened was it for you guys in the lab
theater it was a phenom an email bang
this board was email because he was so
busy I mean there was at one point where
he was like yeah I am on my parents
right now I'm like [__] like holy [__]
like he's killing I ran into push it at
I know a hot 97 in New York singer and I
guess it was right around when my album
came out and he saw the numbers and he
saw the line and he was just like whoa
this is my brother's kids doing
something he just showed me so much
respect which is crazy because like just
dude I listen to this dude forever you
know me and I was like damn I was really
that was like one I know a lot of people
and that was one person where I just may
have such reverence and I was so excited
to meet him such a nice dude and they're
not Elsa said that was when I got into
the radio game I had two guys I was like
what I just want to interview [__]
Nonna's and push a TV with it wax I've
interviewed both of them but in Kanye's
the
for me but if I interview Kanye I could
quit radio VI but um but push a man was
so cool and like one of those guys is
I've always kept I've always kept in
contact always like he's a good dude man
and that's just how it was we just
stayed in touch and I just kind of
reached out to him and was like cuz this
is another thing I'm very I know that's
why I have a lot of features because I'm
not the [__] dude that's like a fan
get all my [__] get all my [__] you
don't like [__] like I like to hold my
own and that's no disrespect to anybody
who might have a bunch of features on
their [__] but me I don't want people to
be like yo you're telling your story not
everybody people can't tell your story
look at it as your first two albums are
really like obviously the second oh man
I loved how you tied in the concept with
the anime theme and all that but like I
played for the next one I think with you
it's like that's am literally under
pressure like I feel like I know you dog
wait
that's why I wanted that's what it was
for it was like this is who I am this is
what I that's why I like the fact that
that the Big Sean feature was it was a
bonus track yeah no that's real that's a
very arrogant and childish gambino oh
well I'm like yo I respect that yeah cuz
you know cuz it's it's you know no man
can a Z that's it
you know what I mean like yeah that's
what I'm saying I just wanted it to be
simple but either way so it was just
amazing that you know when I reached out
to him I was just like yo I have this
crazy conceptual record I was like I've
always wanted to a record with you but I
don't want to just do penny I mean not
to say that it's like it just does
anything because you know like you're
gonna get a crazy verse about some
cocaine for Richard so I was like let's
make it conceptual and crazy and awesome
and then I created this whole like you
know this whole like Columbian
or cartel care yes I know that you're
obviously Bobby Tarantino is due to the
fact that you're huge wouldn't fail of
yeah what is what is your favorite
Quentin Tarantino movie have the last
decade does the thinking I think you
know we can all I don't know is called
fiction number one for you cuz I feel
like that's how I never tell what my
favorite [__] is cuz I stand on the
sched all right that's right in the
front yeah you're gonna tell it and then
fans are always like what's your
favorite Tarantino movie not like uh I
just I don't know why I think it's like
a fun like thing that nobody will ever
know it's like it's like the [__]
cradled in Inception like is he dreaming
is alive this that even though actually
he is away because is his
actually his wedding you know I've never
seen inception what I know man
I even at the same I know listen at the
end of the day I'm a huge movie got to I
just never it's incredible I feel like
what happened someone I love somewhat
spoiled with deception for me they like
kind of told me the concept of it I felt
like [__] no no no no no watch it no it
doesn't matter
even if you know or you know do you want
you to see it doesn't I can sit here and
tell you see this is he that did
whatever the [__] like just don't wait
it doesn't matter like you could bro
that's one of those movies that's so
[__] it's so like what's the work
intricate watching tomorrow yeah just
watch it and like it yeah
she was telling me you guys have got
started working on a beat well he was
working on a B no I was like yo you guys
I got a [__] song now ty ever that's
so funny
we were supposed to do one and then like
we both it just didn't happen like and
then I hit him about the tape but he was
like somewhere it was like it just
wouldn't it just it was gonna make
perfect sense when I bounce off the tape
yeah I know but perhaps someone had made
in Tokyo on a record but then I was like
you know what I'm just gonna give myself
you should be I'm just gonna keep it
myself and push it and then but I think
I'm gonna remake someone made in Tokyo
yeah anyway yeah I hate I hate young
Journal today on Twitter watches what
happened I had a monsoon it was like
what's up fam we gonna make this song
like just fun around put it out there to
get out the fan to hold you guys that's
all I'm saying good because we always
say it Ross I can't were gonna do it
we're gonna do it I never say anything
publicly and he never really says
anything public but I was like [__]
around this tour together like it's
gonna be so fun yeah like I feel like
you know it's obviously Jesus did only
difference between what you guys got
going on she got back hit records you
know she's not an amazing hit record but
I'm glad I got a hit out and and and and
I say that I mean and I don't mean
anything against that I'm talking about
it I'm glad I just want to throw this
out there I'm so [__] glad that I
have like an album like albums because I
can't wait because once the record come
whenever it comes however comes work in
it'll become organic that's gonna be
[__] crazy man cuz like I see what
she's doing
and it's just so amazing like when you
have a record that's not and it's not
just urban or it's not just this was
done it's like a top 40 Red Room where
it's an all man that's amazing so if
you're gonna do it like that's a [__]
amazing way to do it approximately is
that like okay so the your re started
working on the the software that you're
clear out yeah I mean I'm always working
always work no I D
yeah well no not really it's weird me
and me no idea it's never really been
about production
it really has its I've always been about
my conversation or where to go or no you
know what you could do is you could do
this it's like you babies like to become
yeah but it's like really crazy like
he's like Yoda like he can say one thing
and I'll be like oh [__] and it
turn into this old other thing it's
really impossible like I just kind of
check it we check in with each other
yeah whose likes I know they don't you
and Hobson hung out and yeah you would
told me when we chopped up you guys were
like you guys just viably [__] out yeah
we did dogs at home we straight homey
[__] no music [__] oh yeah just homey
[__]
but I'm like Mike who's a spitter yes I
don't know how often I feel like you're
the kind of guy that doesn't lose a lot
of it or not yeah a lot of like but but
it looks like a spitter out right now
that you're like that guy like half a
bar with that dude on the right there's
somebody who you disrespect cuz I feel
like there's not a lot of people that
rap in the calendar that you rat it's
very I mean you'd be hard-pressed to
find anybody that's really relevant in
like that can I mean yo man you're going
on tour right now and you're [__] its
boom back it'll lyrical to that [__]
wise man it's crazy but I appreciate it
but I'm saying like like who's somebody
else you know obviously Kendricks and
Cole's aside like somebody who may be
up-and-coming that maybe you've seen
that you you were may be impressed by
ashes
I mean desert Curry's lit denzel's
[__] yeah he got me my anything like
that mother like that whole new Miami
way was something bro dopest but it's
like a it's like crazy energy on his
[__] is so like and he's got a potential
cuz he can rap but he's got it doesn't
the one thing I appreciate about what
he's doing
nobody sounds like him you don't do not
mine no have you ever heard of booyah
who he is I know yeah who is crazy
he looks like a little homeless kid hey
bro hey no you try to announce my guy
this my god no honey it's cool I
literally saw him like six times in like
two months and he had the same al khair
shirt on every time I saw outcast Bella
I mean of course I haven't seen him
perform but I've seen like up see like
the energy and then the suicide boys
have like they got a [__] thing man
it's it's crazy
that's my sponsor down there they're
like really so cool yet so anyway the
shaman says so yeah after something well
look Oh in Nick caution Nick Carson
GoPro here yes
shout out to [__] pro era no he is I
love time he was always like a little
dude around Joey and he was the last
like he's like the last dude of the crew
to really like he's awesome and he's
[__] dope I [__] him so much yeah
look I was tight mixtape it's only gonna
be online it's not gonna do people go by
in the store no limited art hard copy
run maybe I'll do like a vinyl or
something later but I know it's just
it's fun so that's what I'll just
have some fun turn your phone on I even
feel like I know you say that like but
it feels like I just feel like oh crap I
don't feel to me if I'm no I didn't I
didn't and that's why it like I refer to
it as an album like while I was making
it because it is an album but it's a
mixed day though like it's weird because
I didn't put my it wasn't my blood sweat
tears and [__] oh my god conceptual
and blah it was like that but maybe now
mr. glass some [__] fun I'm still
gonna put my heart into labor say me I
was gonna have some bubbly actually I
guess that can't win it next year next
year next year but like later in the
year like not like January first
like [__] you get that nice feature man
that'd be tight that [__] does like
that yeah now's invite that's all even
such a really cool you gotta you got
your anyone's crazy features like I got
I want to hear [__] logic hop on a
record with you know [__] what I was
gonna I was gonna say sorry huh yeah
that's true yeah that right you're like
by the way sri life is one-off a result
yo thanks a lot
I love the console of the package and
you have to record school slugman is so
[__] like swept on when it comes to
dyno and rides and what my Sears has
done enough handedly yeah it's [__]
crazy man well look I appreciate you as
a man thank you yes sir
Tuggle wife I said oh she chose right
she's not here I'm gonna see you
tomorrow here to be Kelly be a boy I
know I can't wait was last time you've
been back to mail is a visit I know I
see my wife in two weeks me anybody
oh yeah it's out of here then yeah you
might have that baby [__] word up man
logic cooking project who like have that
kind of bollocks